Me dan este polinomio cuadrático 5x al cuadrado -20x más 15 y me dicen que "y" es igual a esto.
Ahora como "y" aparece al cuadrado yo sé que se trata de una parábola, y más aún se trata de una parábola que abre o
hacia arriba o abre hacia abajo, es decir la gráfica de ese polinomio se ve algo así o algo así.
Ahora bien como el término que acompaña "x" al cuadrado, su coeficiente, es positivo es 5,
entonces yo sé que se trata de una parábola que abre hacia
arriba y me preguntó por cuáles son las coordenadas de su vértice.
El vértice en sí es el punto mínimo, en este caso si la parábola abre hacia arriba, el vértice es el punto mínimo
del polinomio cuadrático, y en el caso en el que la parábola abra hacia abajo, el vértice sería el punto máximo.
Pero bueno supongamos que la parábola intersecta al eje "x" en algo así que no sé si sea el caso, pero bien.
Entonces quiero encontrar las coordenadas del vértice y el modo más sencillo es simplemente aplicar una fórmula, que de hecho es bien conocida
y me dice que la coordenada "x" del vértice
vamos a escribirla como "x" vértice
es igual a -"b"
entre 2a, que quizás reconozcan como el primer término en la fórmula cuadrática.
La razón de eso podría ser, de un modo muy intuitivo pensada como que
este punto, el vértice,  su coordenada "x" está justo entre las 2 raíces de este polinomio cuadrático,
pero bueno esto funciona a pesar de que la parábola no intersecte al eje "x" y si sustituyó,
¿Quién es "b"? "B" es el coeficiente que acompaña a "x" y "a" es el coeficiente que acompaña a "x" al cuadrado.
De modo que si sustituyó los valores que corresponden a esta ecuación,
entonces obtengo -"b" sería lo mismo que menos,  "b" en este caso vale -20, así que menos -20
2 - 20 entre 2 veces "a", "a" vale 5, entonces es 2 por 5
menos - 20 es 20, 2 por 5 es 10
20 entre 10 es 2, así que la coordenada "x" del vértice es 2
y ¿Cuál es su coordenada "y"?
La coordenada "y" del vértice la puedo obtener simplemente sustituyendo este valor de "x" en mi polinomio cuadrático
y eso me da que la coordenada "y" del vértice va a ser igual a
5 por 2 al cuadrado
-20 por 2
más 15.
2 al cuadrado es 4 por 5 es 20, -20 por 12 es 40, entonces 20 - 40 es -20
más 15 es -5, de modo que las coordenadas del vértice de esta parábola son
2, -5.
Pero bueno no siempre es bueno simplemente sustituir en una fórmula, entonces vamos a tratar de minimizar este polinomio cuadrático
directamente, y para ello lo voy a reescribir acá abajo, "y" es igual a 5x al cuadrado -20x
más 15. Y mi idea ahora es completar el cuadrado, quiero escribir esto de modo
que tenga un término que tenga que ver con "x" al cuadrado, es decir voy a reescribir esto cómo,
voy a factorizar el 5 y escribir esto como "x" al cuadrado
-20 entre 5 es a 4, -4x voy a dejar un espacio aquí
y luego sumar este 15, más 15.
Quiero completar el cuadrado para este caso, y recuerden que si tengo algo de la forma "x" más "a"
y lo elevó al cuadrado,
obtengo "x" al cuadrado más 2ax
más "a" al cuadrado.
De modo que si solo tengo algo de la forma "x" al cuadrado más
2ax para completar el cuadrado,
tomo el coeficiente de la "x" que en este caso es 4, no, -4 perdón, lo divido entre 2 y
elevó al cuadrado y le sumo eso, así que -4 entre 2 es "a" -2 al cuadrado sería 4,
así que sumó 4 pero, en ese caso ya cambié el valor de esta expresión,
por lo tanto tengo que restar también una cantidad equivalente
a sumar este 4 pero, aquí el 4 está sumado
dentro de un paréntesis que está multiplicando por un 5, por lo tanto no solo estoy sumando 4 estoy sumando 20.
De modo que tengo que restar 20 para
balancear la ecuación,
y esto se convierte entonces en
5 por, esto ahora ya es un cuadrado perfecto, y es "x" - 2 al cuadrado
15 - 20 es -5.
Ahora bien noten que este cacho de aquí siempre es un número que es mayor o igual a 0
5 es positivo "x" -2 al cuadrado
siempre es un número mayor o igual a 0, por lo tanto todo esto es mayor o igual a cero.
A - 5 siempre le estoy sumando un número no negativo, de modo que para minimizar
esta ecuación, tengo que sumarle lo menos posible a -5 y lo menos posible sucede precisamente cuando
"x" es igual a 2,
por que si "x" es igual a 2, entonces 2 -2 es 0, todo esto se hace 0 y obtengo el valor de "y"
igual a - 5 que es precisamente lo que obtuvimos acá arriba.